(soft, upbeat music)
(upbeat electronic music)
- You've got this,
you've got it, all right?
Let's go, let's see some hustle, ladies!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
- Come on ladies, let's hustle.
We're gonna be late.
- Ah, my purse!
- Right here, right here,
come on, let's go.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
- Yup, got it.
(soft, upbeat music)
(moaning)
- You're so cute.
(screaming)
Oh my,
come on, just chop her head off.
That's what we wanna see, right?
They're stupid,
you're cute, though, huh?
(soft, upbeat music)
All right guys, this feels
like a good stopping point.
Let's reconvene at two.
Thanks everyone.
Hi!
Oh, baby's here, hello!
- She just woke up from a nap.
- Can I hold her?
(soft, upbeat music)
(laughing)
(speaking foreign language)
- (foreign language) time!
- Oh my god, I love your accent.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)
(whooshing)
(squeaking)